[Music]
[Applause]
so look this reviews extremely late and
I understand that and I apologize for
the fact that I was not able to give you
my review of movie 43 when it actually
was released I saw this movie because I
was hearing so many things about it it
was kind of one of those things where
everyone was like look if you review
movies you you just you kind of got to
watch it just so you can say that you
actually watched it and you actually put
up with it and you actually sat through
it so that at the end of the year you
could be like yeah I did in fact watch
movie 43 so I went and I saw it I wasn't
thinking about doing a review because I
know I said I was going to it's just I
heard so many things about it and I was
like oh I'd already seen Parker and
Hansel and Gretel and I was just not
ready for another film like that and you
know I went and I saw this movie this is
one of the worst movies that I have ever
seen ever and look when I saw this movie
the trailers the way they promoted okay
they don't really tell you what the
movies about the tagline of the movie is
what is movie 43 it was meant to create
some sort of promotional scheme in which
people are then like wow what's this
movie with all these famous people in it
let's go watch it and figure out what it
is the actual truth of the matter is the
movie isn't about anything so there was
no logical campaign in which they could
promote this film to explain the plot in
a trailer essentially this movie is like
the worst rejected Saturday Night Live
skits all in a row like little
five-minute shorts each featuring famous
and well-known actors look I'm gonna get
really in-depth about this movie okay
because I can't really review this film
I'm gonna call it why movie 43 is wrong
and I'm gonna explain why this movie is
wrong this isn't just some film in which
people are like hey let's make a fun
movie and
maybe cash in a little bit this movie is
wrong on so many levels and not just
because of the content because it's
filled with the most obscene idiotic
content the content in this movie is
just disgusting like it's just it's not
funny it's just absolutely disgusting
and you can tell the point the
filmmakers they're trying to make a
movie in which each skit makes people go
oh that was sick and just nasty and you
that's the entire comedy behind this
movie is you for instance spoilers by
the way throughout this entire video
okay I'm just Lee no spoilers everywhere
from movie 43 the first skit in this
movie is Kate Winslet going to a blind
date who ends up being Hugh Jackman and
Hugh Jackman seems like a nice normal
guy wearing a scarf and everything then
he takes a scarf off and guess what he's
got a scrotum on his neck yeah he's got
balls hanging from where his Adam's
apple is like real balls like just there
and of course no one notices this except
Kate Winslet he never makes mention of
it someone hits it with a plate and he's
like oh I was that hurt this isn't
acknowledged by anyone except her in the
entire scene is literally her just
almost about to regurgitate that's the
entire five minutes kit is oh my
goodness Hugh Jackman's got balls on his
neck other skits in the film include
Naomi Watts and Liev Schreiber who have
a son by the way they're also a couple
in real life now I'll get to that later
yeah they have a son and he's
homeschooled and since typically when
kids are home-schooled they don't get
the same social interactions that they
would at a public school they decide to
humiliate their son in every possible
way by laughing at him while he takes a
bath the mother's like hey you've never
had your first kiss have you
well how about it's from me because the
first kisses are usually really awkward
how about I give you your first kiss and
guess what you know apparently each son
who went to public school doesn't have a
complete experience unless he has an
awkward homosexual experience so how
about the dad Liev Schreiber why'd you
try to come on to him in a little
different ways yeah that's that the
entire movie is filled with skits like
that one of the worst and dumbest ones
is Sean William Scott and Johnny
Knoxville they found a little leprechaun
yeah that leprechauns Gerard Butler and
this guy's in this basement and they
have a little bit of a fight scene
because they want his gold and look I'm
done talking about the skits they're
awful every single one of them is
well not one of them is remarkable Halle
Berry continues her descent into just
crap after her Oscar win she's into just
two nothing so what what is she even
doing now after seeing this movie I just
I had to what like I had to know how
this poufy got made how did this come
about how did this movie become
something that people actually pay to go
see in a theater how did it come about
well let me explain this movie took four
years to make yes this this movie there
was 90 something minutes long filled
with stupid little five minute short
skits took four years to make the second
biggest question on my mind besides how
did this thing get made is how did all
of these famous people agree to be in it
so I did some research first off Hugh
Jackman great guy Oscar nominated right
now this is not a good film to be
released during your Oscar campaign he
agreed to be in this film as a favor for
the producer alright Kate Winslet agreed
to be in the scene with him alright now
you got two big actors right there in
one scene there are articles across the
entire internet confirming this okay I'm
not gonna lie to you they use the star
power of those two names to then get the
next few actors and in the next few and
as their cast was built and assembled by
these big names they continued to say
hey know me Watts you know it's just
like a little two second thing you got
to do you can even do it with your
husband Liev Schreiber and we'll give
you like 800 dollars a day yes they paid
the actors $800 a day to be in this
movie
they continued to guilt-trip each of the
actors into being this movie until they
could assemble enough skits to make a
feature-length running time to put in
theaters this movie has absolutely no
plot so the production behind it said
you know what we'll just market it by
saying what is movie 43 because honestly
we don't know what it is well let's just
let's make it seem like it's some big
thing and somehow Richard Gere's in this
movie who by the way apparently
continued to refuse to be in the movie
after agreeing it and finally they
agreed to move the set to where he lives
to film his scene
this movie is riddled with everything
that is wrong about Hollywood every
single thing that is wrong about
Hollywood is in this movie big-name
actors attached to a project that sucks
so
bad that has absolutely no art to it
whatsoever
a movie that is apparently a comedy but
does not have one laugh in it a movie
that is clearly just meant to take your
money from you and that's it movie 43 is
seriously one of the worst movies I've
ever seen I'm gonna make a statement
right now to you guys because I love you
you guys are great and thank you so much
for watching my videos you guys know
that Dragonball Evolution is my least
favorite movie of all time look that
movie just destroyed my childhood it
like it has a personal thing with me
that movie but I recognize that movie 43
is worse than Dragonball Evolution this
movie is an atrocity to cinema like I'm
serious this movie has everything that's
wrong with Hollywood all over it it is
just it is wrong like I seriously sat
there watching this movie just like it's
one of the most shocking movies I've
ever seen it's like the worst way
because you just sit there and disbelief
like there are so many people out there
who would love to be making movies in
Hollywood or wherever who have true
ideas about what it's like to make a
movie people who are in film school
people who are learning about the art of
filmmaking and then you see this shit
like just there and you're like why and
why are all these famous actors in it
these people who apparently have a love
for movie why are they in this movie
like it's just to stop making movies
like this entirely
whoever it was involved with this movie
just fire them I'm serious
like I never ever say just fire someone
like because that's their job and their
livelihood and their families just fire
the people who came up with this idea
okay just despite all the people who
like it I want to make this movie and
let's make it a movie yes like okay look
all of the actors in this movie you guys
are great I like almost all of them but
seriously never ever do something like
this again let's just take this as a
lesson all right and I think they are
because not one of them is promoting
this movie seriously not one actor
promoted this movie out of all those
people they're all like oh my god what
have I done like right now you can see
Hugh Jackman and his oscar-nominated
role in laymen's Rob or you can go
movie 43 where he's got balls hanging
from his neck oh you could go see Naomi
Watts and the impossible of great
performance or you go see the movie
where she pretends to kiss her son and
humiliates him while he's in the shower
and everything because that's the best
way to raise a kid
look this movie is exactly what's wrong
with the filmmaking industry never ever
make a movie like this again Hollywood
if anyone who is in any power in
Hollywood watches this video please
share it just just share it to your
friends give it to them and say look
this guy knows what's wrong with
Hollywood we need to stop doing this
shit just show it to your friends who
are sick of movies like this show it to
someone who likes to do reviews to show
it to someone who has like a passion for
filmmaking who wants to actually be a
director or a writer or an actor or an
actress or an editor or a sound designer
or anything it's like this is what I
mean like this is what I hate about
Hollywood and maybe someone out there
will actually hear like yes god yes
that's how I feel right now I hate
movies like this and that's why movie 43
is wrong guys thanks a lot for watching
and I apologize this review was a little
bit late and as always if you did like
this video you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]